HOUR AS WELL AS A FEW OTHER MEN.
FIRST,
FIRST, BEFORE HE EVEN GOT TO
HELSINKI TO DROP MANAGED TO SEND
THE WORLD OF POLITICAL
ESTABLISHMENTS INTO MELTDOWN AND
IT WAS A VINTAGE WEEK AND THE
UNTHINKING ANTI- TRUMP BIGOTRY
AND HATE FOCUSING, AS USUAL,
UNSTYLED NOT SUBSTANCE AND
IGNORING, AS USUAL, ACTUAL FACTS
IN FAVOR OF CONDESCENDING
CONTEMPT THAT DONALD TRUMP HIS
SUPPORTERS IN AGENDA.
AS A SERVICE LET'S BACKCHECK THE
ELITIST DISPOSAL OF THE
PRESIDENT EUROPEAN DISRUPTOR,
THEY SAID HE WAKENED NATO IN
FACT AS THE NATO
THE PRESIDENT THAT GOT NATO
MEMBERS TO COUGH UP MORE CASH ON
TOP OF THAT THE TOP IS INCREASED
AMERICA'S MILITARY CONTRIBUTIONS
CAN PUT PRESIDENT OBAMA'S MONEY
FROM NATO, MARK MILITARY
RESOURCES FROM AMERICA AND THAT
NEXT, THE ELITISTS SENT TO DROP
IS WRONG TO TAKE ANGELA MERKEL
OVER TASK.
THE DEAL IS REAL AND REALLY BAD.
, THE FIRST OUT SO RIGHT HERE ON
THE SHOW MONTHS AGO.
WHY IS THE FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT THAT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP POINTING THIS
OUT THEN ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE IDEAL ITSELF SOMETHING THAT
DOES UNDERMINE NATO BECAUSE THEY
ARE BLINDED BY THEIR HATRED OF
TRUMP IDIOTS.
THEN THERE IS BREXIT THE
PRESIDENT WAS ATTACKED FOR
CRITICIZING TERESA MAYS BREXIT
AND HE SAID ABOUT HER PLAN WAS
TRUE WHAT RESUME SAID STANDING
RIGHT NEXT TO THE PRESENT WAS
CALLED THE EU A FELLOW BUT IS A
FULL ON TRADE EXACTLY AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID NOT JUST FOR
AMERICA BUT IT KEEPS AFRICA
EUROPE.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THE EU
TOPIC, RUSSIA.
FIRST, THEY WERE JUST ABOUT
IT OBAMA'S ATTITUDE CRIMEA WAS
IF THERE IS SOMEBODY IN THE
SOUND CLAIM THAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER GOING FORWARD RUSSIA
OVER CRIMEA AND EASTERN UKRAINE
SHOULD SPEAK UP AND BE CLEAR.
YET THE TALKING TOUGH OR
ENGAGING IN MILITARY ACTION THAT
IS TANGENTIAL TO THAT AREA IS
LET'S CHECK THE FACT
DID NOTHING ABOUT THE PROJECT,
THE TOP ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
MUCH TOUGHER ON FIVE-YEAR PLAN
THAT OBAMA EVER WAS, NOT JUST
WITH SANCTIONS BUT HITTING THEM
WHERE IT HURTS, ENERGY POLICY.
THAT, THE BIGGEST EVER STATUS ON
GOVERNMENT HACKING IN AMERICA IS
BEING DONE BY CHINA.
FOR DECADES PREVIOUS
MINISTRATIONS ASKED BY THE
IDIOTS IN THE FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT HAVE STEPPED UP TO
CHINA TO TOP FINALLY WE ARE
HEADING BACK.
THE SAME ELITISTS WANT TO
UNLEASH HELL AND RUSSIA ARE
CRITICIZING HIM FOR STANDING UP
TO CHINA EVEN THOUGH CHINA IS A
MUCH BIGGER BUT AMERICA REALLY?
I'VE USED THE WORD IDIOT A FEW
TIMES AND I THANK YOU CAN SEE
WHY I DON'T MEAN IT
DISRESPECTFULLY BUT THE
BRILLIANT BLACK THAT HAS COINED
THE PHRASE
THE PHRASE I WHY I, INTELLECTUAL
YET IDIOT TO DESCRIBE THE
ELITIST GROUP.
WE'VE HAD A BUCKET FULL OF IT
THIS WEEK WITH MORE TO COME, NO
DOUBT, FROM THE GENERAL
DESTRUCTION UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF HELSINKI, FINLAND TELL ME
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT DON'T